[Music]
[Applause]
former raider quarterback cardinal
quarterback bengal quarterback carson
palmer joining us on the program who
were you rooting for between kansas city
and the cincinnati bengals carson
i was rooting for the bengals i uh no no
fan base deserves this super bowl birth
more than the scentsy bengals
what were you thinking when it was 21-3
i thought there was a shot
things just things really just obviously
went sideways for kansas city they went
from on offense patrick mahomes took
over the first half by just really
taking what the defense was giving him
and then in the second half
he was it was weird he threw that one
touchdown to tyreek hill in the back of
the end zone in the red zone where he
was kind of running around and moving in
the pocket and then rolled out to the
right
and he loves those kinds of plays you
can tell and he kept looking for that in
the second half and what got them
to that big lead in the first half was
just taking what the defense was giving
him and he absolutely stopped doing that
he started dropping back in the second
half moving in the pocket spinning out
rolling left rolling right and it just
wasn't working because the bengals
defense just sat back and covered two
and cover four and played zone and
watched everything underneath them and
didn't give them any of those big shots
down the field i just don't know why
they didn't run the ball
if you're going against a three-man
front
you can get to that second level and if
you set up screen pass whatever it was
it just felt like
maybe ego got the better of them but it
felt like they were trying to do
something great instead of just being
methodical
well and and that's what got them there
mckinnon was unbelievable the last three
weeks i mean that he has been so
difficult to tackle he's been so dynamic
and screen game but really running the
ball downhill
with the absence of edward solaire with
the ankle injury mckinnon came in and
was unbelievable nobody was tackling him
in the first tackle he was breaking
tackles he was explosive and then they
just stopped giving him the ball
unfortunately
but would you rather face
you know pressure or eight guys in the
secondary in a three-man rush as a
quarterback
pressure all day i think every
quarterback is more comfortable when you
know you've got one-on-ones outside it
gets really difficult when they do those
three man prep those three man blitzes
with the three defensive linemen now
you've got eight guys dropping in
coverage more often not covering three
and sometimes four guys so
uh pressure is always a quarterback
quarterbacks are always looking for
pressure joe burrow does such a good job
of diagnosing it and that's why they're
where they are they are not beating
people because their offensive line is
better they are not dominating the line
of scrimmage
joe is
absolutely dominating the line of
scrimmage he's redirecting pressures he
had him in a situation
uh last night where they were bringing a
will free safety blitz a blitz that
could not be picked up he redirected the
offensive line in arrowhead stadium
which believe me is not easy to do
and he is winning he he is beating teams
himself at the line of scrimmage and i
know there's a lot of guys around him
and i'm not saying it's all on him but
he is absolutely taking that team and
put him on his shoulders and got him the
super bowl this doesn't happen to a
second-year quarterback
you just don't see this i mean you see
second-year quarterbacks you think back
when when i was a young qb in the league
and ben roethlisberger came on the scene
and won a ton of games you know as as a
rookie but they won those games because
that was the number one defense in the
league he had jerome bettis he had
antoine randall he had plaxico burris
and you can go on and on
two hall of famers at offensive line
joe's not doing that with the same
supporting cast he is doing it like a 12
13 14 year vet in year two
i mentioned this you know being from the
cincinnati area i just didn't want the
bengals to be embarrassed because
everybody would say oh you're from
cincinnati all the bungles and you you
know this because you played there but
when it was 21-3 that's if you would
have said hey they're going to lose in
dramatic fashion heartbreaking fashion
and i i would have i would have signed
up for that i just didn't want them
embarrassed because this has been a
really great story and they found their
guy and they got their wide receiver and
you got a young coach you got a good
running back uh defense to me won that
game with you know what they did to
patrick mahomes so
uh
it's they might be the team people are
rooting for in the super bowl if you
don't have a you know if you're not
based with the rams you're probably
rooting for the bengals
yeah who doesn't love the underdog who
who doesn't want the second year
quarterback the hometown kid from ohio
to win a super bowl for the bengals i
mean they're going to be the ones that
everybody follows la's you know they
transfer you know moving from st louis
into la
there's some fans that are split in la
with the chargers and the old raiders
back in the day when the raiders were in
la
all of ohio
outside northeastern ohio where
cleveland is is behind the bengals and i
think the midwest is too even um there
was even a bunch of fans in kansas city
at arrowhead it was great to see the
following i can't wait to be in la next
week and see all the bengals fans there
celebrating and enjoying the week we're
talking to carson palmer joining us on
behalf of our good friends at
levelselectcbd.com
how would you assess the quarterbacking
play in the nfc title game
well i think everybody understands why
the rams got matthew stafford but
everybody really quickly forgets how
well jared goff played in 2018 in the
nfc championship in new orleans and beat
the drew brees saints when they were
rocking and rolling and great on defense
now stafford has to prove that he's
worth his weight
for those two first-round picks and i
think a second or third in there too by
winning the super bowl i mean this this
is such a big game for matt this is a
career-making game
again i mean people people dumped on
goff really quickly um but goth had a
lot of success up until that super bowl
game goff played phenomenally in that
nfc championship in new orleans and got
that team there the same thing stafford
just did by getting the
the rams into his first super bowl in la
if he can win this super bowl he proves
everybody right in the building for the
rams
from snead down to mcvay uh tell the
owner stan crunky that this was the
right decision to be made on the other
end of things in san francisco um we got
exactly what we probably all assumed was
gonna happen you know the game was put
on the line when when you have that ball
in your hands and you have a chance to
win at the end of the game and you're
jimmy garoppolo in that situation you no
longer have the advantage you had most
the game which was kyle shanahan calling
the place
the scripted plays the the plays that
kyle can call in from a headset you get
in a two-minute situation like that it's
on you as a quarterback and i think we
all saw what we've we expected to see we
saw it a couple years ago where jimmy
just didn't get it done and that's
probably why we're gonna see him in a
different uniform next year and see trey
lance being the starting quarterback the
niners next year i just didn't
understand if if i'm the niners i know
the rams want the game in the ball in
jimmy garoppolo's hands at the end of
the game that's what they're kind of
preparing for why not run the ball more
why not
i i just i just didn't understand that
the chief's not doing it and the niners
done the rams run the football i mean
they that big offensive line i i just
thought i got to take the ball out of
his hands like i can't have the game on
the line with him trying to win it for
me
yeah i mean we all wanted to see that at
the end of the day you got two
offensive-minded head coaches that are
both calling those plays and
offensive-minded head coaches got there
by throwing it they didn't get there by
running it that's just a natural we got
to get a big chunk we can't run it for
eight we need to throw up for 25 and
another 20 and another 20. and no doubt
i mean it's is
it's an ego thing
i'm sure the monday morning quarterback
and and all those coaches is going back
and gone man i should have run it on
first and ten here i should have run in
on second and long here but i mean at
the end of the day um you're right the
ball was in jimmy's hands and that's not
the situation you want to be in if
you're the 49ers that team got there by
defense and running the football and
when it came down to get into the super
bowl they had to throw it and that is
not their forte i know but i go back to
the super bowl carson when
they should have run the ball they could
have they
i i just don't understand that mindset
you know even when you know shanahan was
with the falcons
they were throwing the ball they didn't
need to throw the ball you were in field
goal range like these are these are
costly costly moments for shanahan you
know he's blown double-digit leads in a
super bowl as a you know offensive
coordinator as a head coach
uh with last night um you know that's
inexcusable for a guy who's that that's
that's sharp and and you assume that you
learn from your past mistakes and move
forward and unfortunately like like i
said i mean you got andy reid one of the
greatest offensive play callers past
game innovators kyle shanahan one of the
greatest young offensive coordinators
and he's great in the run game and he's
great in the pass game and you naturally
as a as a coach that's calling plays you
naturally feel like we need more yards
than we can get in the run game it's
just not easy to do when you're in that
position obviously man
and i couldn't help but watch when odell
beckham had whatever nine catches eight
catches last night
why didn't somebody else
swoop in like uh green bay
like what what am i missing with odell
beckham even the browns i know there's
ego involved in this but
it just
you can't help but watch that and go
even though he's had surgeries and he's
a step slower quicker
man he's still a game breaker he's an
impactful player
it's outside noise it's outside noise
it's that media labeling him as a prima
donna not a team guy
uh all the headlines we you know when
when times were bad for elder beckham
you heard you know all he cares about
his catches he doesn't want to win
all these teams except for the rams
listen to the outside noise the rams
said you know what we need to get him in
the building we've got vets we've got
aaron donald one of the best players on
defense we've got a young sean mcveigh
that any receiver would love to listen
to a vet quarterback and stafford andrew
whitworth that left tackle who's like
60. they have so much
leadership they have so much so many
veterans in the room they said even if
he is even if all these articles are
right and he's a prima donna and he
cares about himself and doesn't care
about the team we've got enough guys to
bring him together maybe it is that or
maybe all these articles are wrong about
obj and he just wants to win but the
rams figured it out would you rather
have joe burrow or matthew stafford for
this one game
joe burl
would you rather have cooper cup or
jamar chase for this one game
i'd rather have cooper cup because he's
been there before
it's still amazing to watch like i'm
still amazed these defenses somehow
forget the cooper cup
won the triple crown of wide receivers
why is that well
it's funny too because you watched that
first game in in the scentsy uh the game
in arrowhead with the chiefs
jamar the the time they played just like
a month or you know six weeks before
that in cincy and obviously the bengals
won jamar went for a quarter thousand
yards
and this year i mean think about that he
went for 266 yards in one game they
figured out they needed to shut him down
but every it was amazing and what was so
mature about joe burrow's play is every
time they didn't double him which was
very rarely and he was one on one joe
got on the ball there was very few
instances where jamar was one-on-one and
joe figured it out diagnosed the defense
found his one-on-one in his best player
and gave him the ball
you know he didn't have 266 yards but he
still greatly affected that game and
they did a ton of stuff i mean that
zach's scheme with him in the backfield
motioning in and out of different spots
he was so difficult to figure out where
jamar was going to land and end up but
the chiefs did a really good job of
finding out where that was going to be
and doubled him but the very few times
where he was not doubled he got the ball
in his hands and joe figured it out but
i mentioned cooper cup
i mean it felt like the niners forgot
that he is
was an mvp candidate and and you know
did all of these things the regular
season
yeah and and again you i can point the
finger and it's great it was great by
stafford it was great by cup but that's
a sean mcvay kevin o'connell finding a
way
he he was all over the place cooper cup
was on the outside he was on the inside
he was motioning he was shifting you
don't
when you have a guy that's as smart as
some of these receivers we're seeing in
jamar and cooper cup
they don't just have to line up at x on
the left-hand side of the field anymore
they are so smart they can motion them
they can shift them they can put them
inside they can put them on a three by
one side you just don't know where he's
going to be and as easy as to say is
don't let cooper cup get the ball
he's all over the place you don't know
where he's going to line up it's so
difficult to do and again stafford a lot
like joe burrow when he was in those
situations when he was one-on-one he got
him the ball are you going to be in l.a
next week
i will i'll see you next week maybe we
could go to usc and
walk around and uh throw the fight on
just walk around campus well maybe we
could uh you know throw the football
around or something like that let's do
it would you dress like a trojan
like a trojan
i've got a trojan uh halloween outfit
can i bring that for you
yes
all right i'll throw you we'll go to the
coliseum we'll throw some routes
[Laughter]
we could we could dress like a pack of
trojans how's that
no i don't want to dress up just you
[Laughter]
all right well we'll see you uh we'll
see you in la next week
sounds great thank you buddy that's
carson palmer his weekly appearance
during the nfl season brought to you by
our partner level select cbd looking for
next level relief visit
levelselectcbd.com